to talk about a lot of things so I'm
going to be talking also about
information theoretic problems in
control and in this particular workshop
or this semester we've thought a lot
about various kinds of autonomous
systems they varied in terms of the size
of operation in terms of the time scale
at which they operate and in terms of
the specific control application that
they're tackling one example of such a
system is an autonomous drone which is
similar to the example that Victoria
brought up and in this particular case
this drone for example will depend
heavily on a set of motors as well as
sensors maybe a wireless channel to
communicate with some kind of base
station to be able to achieve the task
that it is trying to complete and what
I'm going to be focusing on in this
particular talk is how uncertainty and
unreliability in the operation of these
motors and these sensors is actually
going to affect our ability to stabilize
and control such a system
so if you think back to the beginning of
this semester at the boot camp where
there were some tutorial talks on
control what was introduced was for
example a standard model for a simple
linear control system which looks very
similar to what we have here and is
exactly what Victoria introduced in the
earlier talk so here we would have X as
being say the system state and would be
a time index we're thinking about a
discrete time system Y might be the
observation that is being observed by
the controller over some kind of sensing
mechanism the control U is being the
controller is computing U which is based
on these previous observations Y and Y
is then being transmitted to the
controller are actually being actuated
over some actuation mechanism and then
there is of course some additive
disturbances such as W and V in these
systems that for example were introduced
in the bootcamp or even the system that
Victoria introduced one thing we
commonly assume is we assume that we
know the exact model parameters of the
system so we assume usually that this a
matrix the B matrix the C matrix are all
fixed and known to us exactly and you
know maybe this is known through some
kind of system ID we understand the
parameters of the system and then we go
on to control it what I want to focus on
in this particular talk is what happens
when actually we might not know exactly
what these system parameters are what
happens when they might be random they
might be time varying what are our
fundamental limits on how we can
stabilize and control these systems and
furthermore can we understand these
uncertainties in the model from an
informational perspective this is
another kind of uncertainty it's
different from a traditional
communication uncertainty but can we
understand their effects in a similar
way
and I'm not going to be able to talk
fully about all kinds of uncertainties
in the system so I'm not going to be
able to cover uncertainties in a and B
and C in this talk I'll be focusing
primarily on uncertainties in the B and
the C parameters but building on
actually the talk that Victoria just
have we also have some work together
that focuses on what happens when the a
in the problem that she was just talking
about is also drawn randomly and how can
we adopt the scheme the zoomin zoom-out
scheme that she just mentioned to deal
with that case as well I'm I'm sure
either of us would be happy to answer
questions about that later if there's
time so let me talk about why we would
want to understand these kind of systems
with random parameters where do they
actually show up so one example of such
a of where this might show up is in the
case where there's some kind of timing
jitter or synchronization errors in your
system in this case if you have an
exponentially growing state and you have
some sampling mechanism that's actually
trying to sample your system at certain
times instead of sampling at a time T
you sample it at some time T plus Delta
where Delta is random what you're gonna
end up with is going to be a
multiplicative noise or an unknown
parameter in your system and this can
show up on your system gain it can show
up on your observation game another
example of where this might show up is a
commonly used scheme in control called
pulse width modulation so this is used
for example to control motors on drones
it's used in thermostats probably people
who work on the power grid here have
also encountered this the idea here is
that you have a voltage pulse and what
you're controlling your control input is
actually the length of the pulse but in
the event that you have some jitter
actually on your voltage so instead of
being here at jitter is just by a little
bit again this is going to show up as a
multiplicative noise or an uncertain
parameter in your control model and what
we want to understand are what are the
fundamental limits that are imposed
by these kinds of uncertainties in your
system so today as I mentioned I'm going
to focus on uncertainty on the actuation
side and contrast it with uncertainty on
the sensing side and what we will see is
that when your uncertainty is on the
actuation side linear strategies turn
out to be optimal but when the
uncertainties in the sensing side linear
strategies actually turn out to be
surprisingly suboptimal despite how
similar the problems are and we'll
understand this a little bit more and in
the process of this I will talk a little
bit about you know how we can understand
this problem on the actuation side and
try to understand a fundamental idea of
well how fast can we actually stabilize
a system is there a limit that is
imposed fundamentally by these
uncertainties on our ability to
stabilize I'll talk about this on both
the actuation side as well as the
sensing side if there's time at the end
I'll talk about how this idea of
thinking about things informational e
can help us quantify the impact of
having some site information about these
parameters and how this can help us
design better strategies not entirely
sure if I'll get to this part of the
talk again the work that I'm talking
about today is building on a large set
of work that has been done over many
years
Victoria alluded to a lot of it I won't
go into a lot of these details in the
interest of time but we're building
heavily on ideas from for example robust
control and the uncertainty threshold
principle I was just having a
conversation in the break about some of
these ideas but here I'm going to be
taking a more stochastic control
perspective and also we're building
fundamentally on results such as the
data rate theorem ideas from internment
common filtering and most importantly
ideas that go back to Whitson housen on
you know the value of information in
control from the 70s
so let's start and first I'm going to
focus on uncertainty on the actuation
side so let's think about what happens
when your motor has some uncertainty in
ER to think about the pwn PWM example
here so let me now give you exactly what
the what the model is so here I want to
think about a very simple scalar system
and here let's say X is the system state
as usual and it's evolving according to
this equation X at time n plus 1 is a
times X n plus BN times u n to focus on
one unknown an uncertain thing at a time
let's say a is fixed and known but BN is
capturing our actuation uncertainty so
let's say BN is coming IID from some
distribution PB which we know and let's
say further that we have a perfect
observation so U is allowed to depend
causally on all of the previous system
observations let's say X naught is drawn
from a normal distribution but this is
not particularly important there's not
gonna be any memory restrictions on the
controller but we are using causal
control what is our objective here okay
we have some system what we want to do
with it our goal is as a standard in
control is to drive the system to some
fixed point without loss of generality
we're going to choose this to be zero
and to think about a fundamental
requirement for this if we're going to
think focus initially on second moment
stability so we want to make sure that
the second moment of the system is
always going to be bounded
okay great let's start playing with this
system just a little bit the natural
thing to try is to try what happens with
the simple linear strategy so let's just
take you to be some scaler D times X
ofin and see what happens so turns out
that this was exactly what is explored
by the uncertainty threshold principle
in their work they focus on BN being
drawn from a Gaussian distribution but
the same strategy exactly what they do
applies even more generally even when BN
is not Gaussian and what you can see of
spare the details of the algebra here is
that this D times the N times xn just
pulls out so xn just comes out exactly
here and what is of interest is actually
the second moment of this random
variable a plus D times BN you can do
some very simple calculus to signed out
what is exactly the best D what is the
best scalar multiple that you can use to
minimize this in a greedy fashion you
can compute this D
I heard that it's okay
I just wanted to build up more dramatic
still my first point okay
so what we're saying is that let's say
you did some you did some algebra and
you computed what is the optimal linear
control you can do this by just doing
some simple calculus and here you can
show well this system is only going to
be stabilizable if your gain a which is
known a square is smaller than one plus
mu square over Sigma squared where mu
and Sigma are the mean and standard
deviation of this random variable B and
this is exactly the condition that was
found by Athens and co-authors and
furthermore they used a simple dynamic
programming argument to show that this
is actually the exactly optimal strategy
for this problem if Sigma B squared goes
to zero then you know exactly B right
and so if Sigma B square goes to zero
then you're always you're always good
okay so let's play with this but since
we sent you know let's look instead at
the case what happens when actually mu B
is zero so let's take a very simple
example which is almost trivial let's
look at this case where B is now uniform
on minus 1 to 1 and we see here that in
this case the optimal control is
actually to set u to be exactly equal to
zero why is this the case let's say I
tell you exactly that your state is
going to be you know you're moving along
this line your state is exactly here and
you're going to put in like this amount
of effort to move to that state but this
B can flip your sign so when I put in my
control I don't know if I'm gonna
actually get closer to my target or if
I'm going to move equally far away from
my target and given that I don't know
this in a second moment sense it turns
out that the optimal thing to do is just
to do nothing and so what we see is that
the best
symma made that you can stabilize is
when the system is already essentially
self-stabilizing or is smaller than what
so if I was to choose some a larger than
one for example one point four and I
choose the optimal control for a second
moment stabilization what I get is a
plot like this on a log-log scale I see
that xn is blowing up exponentially this
is why it's a log log plot so the lines
are straight lines but what if now I
told you that actually I can find a
control such that I can generate the
following trajectories for this exact
same system with a equal to one point
four again on a log log plot what I see
here now is that all of these
trajectories these are I think 50 or 100
trajectories these are all decaying
exponentially so we just computed that
Oh actually the optimal control in the
second moment sense is to do nothing
to have zero something about the
language because it's different only if
it's stable in a second moment sense if
and only if I'm saying that the largest
a for which you can stabilize in the
second moment sense so I'm trying to
find the largest a or alternatively I'm
trying to find the maximal decay rate
you're exactly coming to my point which
is that maybe second moment sense of
stability which is what we traditionally
look at in control isn't the only sense
of stability that we should be looking
at and this has been understood in the
literature before
yes so I'm trying to do something I'm
assuming that I know the distribution it
might be the specific distributions you
get better one so it turns up yes that
is true it turns out that for second
moment stability all that matters is the
mean and the variance but for other
notions of stability the entire
distribution of B is actually exactly
what will matter until
okay so what I want to now say is that
instead maybe we should look at this
other notion of stability which is
stability and probability and this has
been introduced in the past in the
literature by people such as Sardar
Excel or matt bevin's how can as well as
co-authors and here what I want to think
about is I want to think instead of
looking at the second moment I want to
think about the density of the system
state and I want to say that I'm going
to say the system is stable and
probability as long as the probability
mass is not running off to infinity so I
can for so I can make sure that for
every n the system state is bounded in a
box with high probability with
probability 1 minus Epsilon and this is
a notion of stability that is basically
the weakest notion of stability if you
do not have stability in probability you
cannot have any notion of moment
stability which is easy to see so now
the question is well you know here I did
some calculation and I got some control
that showed that these system states
were actually decaying the question is
for what lard how large can this a be so
that I can still generate these decaying
trajectories you know can I keep coming
up with some strategy or the other if I
make a a million is there still going to
be some trajectory or some some control
that is going to decay my system and
this need not be the case and so the
question is what is this fundamental
limit on my ability to actually
stabilize the system and so we want to
actually define this you want to say
that this maximum growth rate we want to
understand what this is what is the
maximum growth rate for which there
exists a control strategy such that I
can keep my system stable in probability
it turns out that we can actually
compute the value of this and it's given
by this very simple expression and the
nice thing that we see is that as a
byproduct of this linear strategies can
actually are optimal in the sense that
any aid that can be stabilized can also
be stabilized by a linear strategy and
I'm thinking about stability in the
sense of stability and probability if
you have a system that's controllable
you just been talking about scale at
least so yes so the vector case turns
out to be somewhat more tricky two
dimensions is somewhat understandable
but in three dimensions like random
walks are always diverging so things
become slightly more slightly more
complicated and the naive
generalizations which I thought would
easily work out do not work out quite as
easily so vector cases become become
slightly more complicated for some
simple vector situations we can we can
understand this in the cases where for
example the noises are symmetric but
this is still some some work in progress
and I don't fully understand the general
vector case so it's an interesting open
question
what's the connection between c0o so c0
is the largest log a such that I can
actually have this system system be
stable in probability so I can have
these decaying trajectories it might not
be equal to X so in this case I'm
focusing on this very very simple case
to understand what's going on yeah these
controls do distribute depend on the
distribution of B yes and yeah you you
would compute basically this optimal D
according to exactly this this
calculation
so where is this where is this coming
from let me give some intuition about it
so for the achievability where is this
let's say we just use a basic linear
strategy so let's say u n is just a
times some D times some yn then I can
write xn as basically this product of
random variables times this initial
state X naught and now if I just want to
minimize this I can just take a log and
this product will become become a sum
and I'm going to get exactly an
expression just like this so I can see
it exactly how a linear strategy can
achieve this bound and for the converse
argument which is the more interesting
part I won't have time to go into
details but it's basically a martingale
argument that shows that even if you
used a non linear strategy its
performance will always be bounded by
the performance of this linear strategy
so the nice thing about having this
explicit formula is that actually what
we can do is we can compute this
quantity so what I'm plotting here is on
the x-axis is the log of mu B - Sigma B
where mu is the mean and Sigma is the
standard deviation of this random
variable B the y-axis is the log of the
maximum growth a I am looking at it for
three distributions the first is when B
is drawn from a Gaussian distribution
the next is when it's drawn from an
erasure and the third is Ben is drawn
from a uniform and if we were to look at
second moment stability what we see is
exactly this green curve all three of
these actually follow exactly the same
curve and basically you see is that as
mu is going to zero this control
capacity or a maximum log that we can
stabilize is also going to zero but now
if we think about stability and
probability let's say for the uniform
case or for the Gaussian case we see
that actually in a stability and
probability sense we can actually
stabilize for some a that's strictly
larger than zero so this is for the
uniform this is for the Gaussian and
turns out for the erasure case we
actually have if we were to think about
stability and probability we actually
have an infinite maximum tolerable
growth rate why is this the case because
even if I get a string of zeros with
probability one eventually I'm going to
get a perfect control that's going to
hit and then I will be able to send my
system to zero and have this infinite
decay rate
it turns out that it's not just second
moment and stability and probabilities
are two notions we can actually think
about this as a family of notions of
stability by looking at different
moments of stability so we can think
about stability of the a dearth moment
of the system state and say what is the
maximum a for which we can stabilize
something in the ADA moment sense and I
won't go into the details of the
definition or anything but just I'll
show you this plot so what this is
showing is on the x-axis as the moment
of stability that is being considered on
the y-axis again we're plotting the
maximum growth this point at which all
of these curves intersect or they're
concurrent is the two two points so
we're looking at the second moment
stability and here basically what we see
is that the Gaussian be being Gaussian
be being uniform be being an erasure
Channel all behave exactly the same so
if we were to focus exclusively on
second moment stability as we mentioned
earlier it's just the mean and the
standard deviation that matters you
cannot differentiate between the shapes
of the distributions but when you start
looking at different moments you see
that actually these behave quite
differently and furthermore as ADA is
the moment of stability tends to zero
actually be converge exactly to this
notion of stability and probability so
the limit of ceará as ADA goes to zero
we can prove is exactly the C naught
that I defined earlier and we can also
define a notion of zero error control
capacity which is what we think of in
robust control where we have we were
very much where we might have worst-case
noise and as era goes to infinity we're
ending up in that extreme yeah and this
I'm plotting for a specific beaver this
mu 2 Sigma ratio is is 3 so that was
exactly the kind of motivation that
initially led to oh let's see if can be
can can we understand this as some kind
of capacity just because of this power
1/2 log 1 plus mu squared over Sigma
squared which is also why I've been
making these plots with this log SNR but
it's it's a cute coincidence that this
happens this says this was also actually
noticed Nicola Ilya had this like as a
comment in one of his papers that Oh in
this special case in the second moment
this this also happens but uh I think
intellectually or philosophically
there's this seems to extent but this
formula is just happens too much
okay and so one other nice thing that
happens as a side effect of this is that
now that we have this characterization
of the maximum growth rate in bits we
can also actually quantify the value of
site information in control so if I was
to give you some extra bits exactly
about let's say this uncertainty and B I
can compute exactly how how this would
affect the maximum a that I could
actually stabilize the system by if I
have time at the end I'll talk a little
bit more about this but I'm not entirely
sure the nice thing is it's like a
simple conditional expectation that we
can actually also compute how much time
do I have I'll just briefly talk a
little bit about this contrast on the
sensing side so here I want to now
contrast this actuation uncertainty with
uncertainty on the sensing side and
let's think now about instead of having
this multiplicative noise under control
this multiplicative noise being on the
sensing side so let's think of Z as
being drawn from some distribution let's
say a Gaussian and again let's now go
back to thinking about the usual second
moment stability if we were to try and
do the same thing that we did in the
other case let's try and do the linear
strategy turns out that the you know
maximum decay rate that you can achieve
using a linear strategy whether the
multiplicative uncertainty is on the
fencing or the control is actually
exactly the same this is because when I
just put D times Z times xn as in terms
of un the the algebra is the same there
the controller cannot just tell the
difference between multiplicative
uncertainty on the actuation versus
multiplicative uncertainty on the
sensing when it's restricted to doing
linear things and so here we have this
achievability but we do not know whether
this is optimal the same techniques that
were used in the uncertainty threshold
principle to prove that this is often
don't actually work and for a long time
I was wondering oh you know maybe I just
can't make them work but turns out that
they don't work for a good reason and
that's because in this case linear
strategies are actually suboptimal and
to see why that's the case
think about the following situation
let's say your Z was drawn from a normal
1 1 and let's say you saw the following
string of observations you saw 2 then
you saw 1 then you saw a 4 then you saw
3 and then suddenly you saw a million
with this history does it make sense to
just use a linear control that's
memoryless and just assumes that the
state is now something close to a
million probably not probably in this
case what this is saying is that oh you
just had an atypical noise realization
ignore this observation and you know do
something that seems more reasonable so
this says that oh well maybe a linear
memoryless strategy is not going to be
optimal can we use somehow memory it
turns out that if we try to convert if
we try to use a linear memory full
strategy that uses the previous
observations this is not going to help
and you can actually prove that if
you're restricted to using the linear
strategy the linear memory less is
optimal why is this the case because
when you take a linear when i when i do
when i remove my best linear estimate
i'm basically making my state orthogonal
to my to my observation i'm removing
this projection and so my next
observation is not has no has no
information about the state because I've
already I've already removed anything
from the past so they own the new
observation is only related to the new
noise so fundamentally what you have to
do is something nonlinear and what we
have is basically a simple nonlinear
strategy that actually strictly
outperforms the linear strategy and what
it really is a hack strategy this is far
from optimal and I think a really
interesting open question is what is the
optimal strategy in this case what we
see with this very simple strategy what
I'm plotting here
again musi which is the mean of Z and
the y-axis is basically the ratio of the
optimal a that can be or the maximum a
that can be stabilized using the
nonlinear strategy to that which can be
stabilized using the linear strategy and
subtracting 1 because that's trivially
that trivially works and you can see
that this nonlinear strategy can do
infinitely better than the linear
strategy so the question is of course
like how much better can you do can you
do unbounded ly better turns out that
that's not the case we can prove a
converse result that says that actually
there is a maximum a beyond which any
strategy linear or nonlinear cannot
stabilize the system and it's
interesting that to prove this actually
we had to go back to this notion of
stability and probability basically sure
that this cannot be stabilized in
probability by looking at the density of
the system state and how its evolving
because it cannot be stabilized in
probability it also cannot be stabilized
in a second moment sense in the interest
of time I'm really not going to go
through the the proof of this but I'm
happy to talk more but what I think is a
really interesting open question is this
bound this converse bond that we have
and the achievability are really quite
far off and a really interesting
question is well can we close this gap
the problem is so simple to write down
but we do not know what the optimal
control strategy is for this kind of
system
so with that I guess I can stop unless
people are really interested in I think
I'm out of time I I can okay so then
I'll tell you a little bit about this
site information part that I I didn't
talk much about so for this to talk
about how excited information is
interesting and why I think this is an
interesting direction I want to go back
to a problem that has been looked at
many times in control it's very related
to the intermittent Kalman filtering
problem or the drop control problem and
here let's think about a vector system
let's think about a vector system where
each is being controlled by a scalar
controller and what's happening here is
that the system is observed perfectly
the control is a scalar control but it's
dropped with some probability PE so the
probability P all you send is 0 and this
problem has been studied by Nicola Ilya
Sardar yüksel Lukas konato and as well
as others and a combination of these
results actually helps us understand the
exact trade-offs first for stabilizing
this problem again in the second moment
sense and let's say we have we're
thinking about a diagonalized system
with eigenvalues lambda 1 lambda 2 all
distinct along the diagonal then all
these results show that this system is
stabilizable in a second moment since
when the system growth which is the sum
of the logs of the unstable eigenvalues
is smaller than half log 1 over PE where
PE is the drop probability of this
channel so let's just plot this and on a
log-log scale this is just a straight
line so we see basically that as the
system gets more and more unstable
the tolerable drop probability keeps on
decreasing the question of course is can
I've been talking about site information
can we somehow provide site information
to this problem
to actually improve the performance of
the system so what kind of site
information is available here well
there's only one parameter in the system
which is the drops that are happening so
can we somehow provide site information
about the drops it turns out that if you
have some kind of Mac layer protocol or
some scheduling protocol it might well
know that oh I'm seeing some congestion
in the system the next few projects few
packets are probably going to be dropped
and this information could potentially
be given to a controller that could then
use it to plan exactly what its controls
are and so what we observe is that
actually it turns out that if you were
to provide the site information about
all future arrivals and drops in the
system to the controller it cannot
actually move from this blue line of
performance to this to this green line
so you get a scaling gain by providing
this non-causal site information so the
future arrivals is I'm thinking of
basically an infinite sequence of every
single drop or every single arrival
that's going to happen it's equivalent
for example in let's say if you had a
two-dimensional system to just know when
is the next arrival that will also get
you this performance so you will tell
yeah yeah so you were in the realization
that I'm operating it so right now I'm
yeah so one particular realization yeah
exactly
and turns out that this actually this
green line matches the performance of
this very related problem which is the
intermittent common filtering problem
so here what was happening is now you
again have a vector system but it's
being observed over a scalar channel
which is lossy and here instead of the
sum of the logs at the eigenvalues
mattering actually all that matters is
the log of the maximum eigen value so in
this case somehow this observation
problem is easier in fact you can
tolerate higher drop probability than
the control problem and what we're
seeing is that by providing this future
information about the drops we can match
the performance of this observation
problem in a sense the state is sending
almost all stuff that you're sending and
then if there's a drop you can send it
later on I mean where is its delayed
feedback you can you can store stuff
that stays where you're sensing it's a
store today yeah if it goes through
finding it doesn't know to then send it
on a future time
but you will affection beginning today
feedback to the controller yeah so I
think that would be sometimes I think
that would be actually equivalent so you
so you're saying instead of giving the
future drops you're saying just store
the current state why would I send I
would I send the previous information
when I could stand the current state
which is more useful for me because my
controller is not has no I'm not
assuming any bounds on the power of my
controller okay I think you could
retransmitted but it might be more
valuable to transmit the new information
as opposed to the old information
because I'm going to act now so I think
if I think if you were to do some kind
of incremental coding then that would
that would be useful but I think it
might not be that different
but yeah let's just quickly finish so
basically you were pointing out that you
know knowing the infinite future is
somewhat unreasonable which is indeed
somewhat unreasonable so it's a good
thing to point out but you can actually
get a similar scaling gain by just
having one step of look ahead so I just
need to know whether the next packet is
going to be dropped or not and of course
two steps of Luke ahead would get you a
little bit better and a little bit
better and so on but with that I I will
actually conclude I didn't have really
time to talk about the case when the
system gained a itself is random but
what we did talk about is that first I
think this interesting observation that
multiplicative noise on the actuation
side is somehow information
theoretically harder to tackle than this
multiplicative noise on the sensing side
and this kind of I feel model
uncertainty can be really thought about
as informational bottlenecks very
similar to the rate limited control that
Victoria was talking about and I think
there's many interesting open questions
at this intersection
for example there's this like need for a
tight achievability converse pair in the
sensing problem that I talked about but
there's also a lot of interesting
questions in understanding how and when
sight information can help how can we
quantify it so on and so forth thank you
[Applause]
so in the second situation where you
have multiplicative noise on the sensor
side that's a non classical expulsion
problem so it's not
so I'm assuming that let's say Z has
some density that's that's an important
assumption let's say X naught also has
some density you can be any function of
Y naught u n can be any function of Y
naught 2 y n so of causal controller
then I'm saying that this for any
strategy or choose your M no matter how
big you choose your box your probability
mass is going to run out of that box so
you're not going to be stable in
probability even if Z is fixed sign yes
even even then even then that will
happen for large enough a and this a is
this is very large so but I I mean I
don't think this is this a is very large
as a function of our proof technique not
as a function of I think the fundamental
limit on a will be quite small you need
a positive variance on the absolute yes
yes yes the positive variance on z is an
option if you as yeah
is the only assumption
I so so some of I have some work with
some co-authors on looking at exactly
when B is B is a matrix and looking at
vector versions of this problem
fundamentally it's a very difficult
problem involves but for special cases
we can have some results I think taking
them fully to actually practice is quite
a ways away this is focusing really gone
there's a lot more work to be done yes
it's been asked since the first part of
your talk you essentially assumed a
linear system but it seemed like you
should be unified around linear function
should be able to figure out what's the
appropriate movement which so a linear
function so you mean like like some here
so
I think that's a very interesting
question I think it'll require some work
to precisely figure it out it getting it
tight would be definitely something
challenging but I think
well if you had control costs here can
you study trade-offs I think it's also
also a really good question I think the
exact techniques that work here will not
go through as easily but I think that is
one of the very important questions
right
like for example really all of these
results are fundamental using the fact
that oh you know I'll let you grow very
large if X grows very large and clearly
that's not going to some budget on
designing sensors are actually raised
with yeah that's exactly where I I want
this to go these are like theoretical
results in the in the simple case but I
think it's interesting to say that well
you know again abstracting away a lot
from these theoretical results but what
this is saying is that if you want to
have if you're gonna have some some
variants and you're gonna put it either
on your B or your C put it on your C
right it's saying that spend your budget
on having a high-quality actuator
because a low-quality sensor you can
compensate by computation on the control
side but a low-quality actuator there's
nothing you can do
there's no noise at all in the system
the one with the V is fixed right so so
fundamental is important to have a
density yeah yeah so like think about
like this would hold with exactly yeah
with these with if Z is either 2 or 3
this does not hold I'm I'm critically
relying on the fact that Z has a density
so Z is uniform between 2 and 3 or Z is
uniform between 2 and 2.1 it's still hot
[Applause]